dernière ligne droite pour la politique
agricole commune les négociations sur la
réforme de la pac et battent leur plein
à bruxelles en vue de finaliser un
accord cette semaine pour plus de
précision va tout de suite retrouvé
notre reporter ben hassen chébili les
devant le ministère de l'agriculture à
paris
[Musique]
bonjour bassem alors les ministres
européens de l'agriculture ont entamé
hier une réunion de deux jours pour
donner un coup d'accélérateur aux
tractations bruxelles qui doit
impérativement s'entendre pour que la
nouvelle pac entre en vigueur
bonjour olivier effectivement c'est un
peu compliqué à bruxelles notamment pour
les ministres de l'agriculture des 27
états membres qui sont en pleine course
comme pour la réforme de cette politique
agricole commune qui doit rentrer en
vigueur assez rapidement et en attendant
dans pas mal de pays de l'union
européenne et notamment en france et
agriculteurs sont en colère notamment
sur la répartition de ce budget qui est
prévu pour la politique agricole commune
beaucoup d'agriculteurs en colère mais
également des ong greenpeace
confédération paysanne ou encore wwf eux
notamment ce groupement le hac ont fait
don de confédération paysanne il dénonce
un statu quo notamment après leur rendez
vous avec monsieur delorme indiqué le
ministre de l'agriculture un rendez-vous
qui étaient ici dans ce bâtiment juste
derrière moi qui le ministère de
l'agriculture
dernière ligne droite comme vous l'avez
dit à bruxelles pour cette réforme de la
pac les pays membres veulent absolument
verdir cette agriculture insuffisante
pour les ong
ce sont des réformes et des projets qui
ne respectent pas la nature ni à
l'environnement
les ministres sont en réunion depuis
hier encore aujourd'hui un branle bas de
combat une dernière ligne droite pour
pouvoir s'accorder mais c'est un peu
compliqué de s'accorder entre tous ces
pays alors que cette réforme doit entrer
en vigueur notamment à partir du 2
janvier 2023 avec un budget assez
colossal de 387 millions
on d'euros et toute la problématique est
de savoir comment répartir ses 387
millions d'euros à travers les 27 pays
membres la feuille de route
elle avait déjà été adopté par les
différents ministres et les 27 pays
membres
objectif et surtout ce qui pose problème
olivier en ce moment c'est notamment la
question de la baisse des pesticides
dans l'agriculture européenne les
vingt-sept souhaiteraient les baisser à
moins 50% d'ici 2023 compliqué pour
certains comparent pour certaines
associations agricoles et notamment
autre problème dans le débat c'est le
système des éco régime c'est à dire
qu'il va y avoir des primes qui seront à
allouer à certains pays et certains
agriculteurs qui notamment mettront les
bouchées doubles notamment concernant
une agriculture plus verte - pesticides
et plus écologiques problème c'est que
ces choses qui sont impossibles voire
très compliquée à mettre en place dans
des délais assez courts et notamment en
manque de budget certaines associations
dénoncent un green machine qui est en
train de s'opérer à bruxelles les pays
membres le ils ont peur d'une
nationalisation de cette pac c'est à
dire qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord sur la répartition du budget
surtout de la mise en place de certaines
réformes qui sont prévues par la pas
qu'ils ont peur que chaque pays fasse un
petit peu ce qu'il veut ce qu'il peut
avec ses agriculteurs
tout cette peur de nationalisation de la
politique agricole commune en attendant
ici en france et à cri tuteurs sont en
colère et ils ont décidé d'organiser un
événement à partir de 11h30 ça sera du
côté de la porte des lilas et bien sûr
olivier on sera avec eux pour suivre ce
mouvement de colère des agriculteurs
français
merci beaucoup bassam pour toutes ces
précisions bassin chebbi en direct
devant le ministère de l'agriculture à
paris